salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche c'est
donc le jour des explications et pour la
première fois depuis le 1er janvier je
ne suis pas tout seul pour une
explication avec léonard léonard si vous
connaissez pas il fait des vidéos fun je
regarde je me marre et je me pose pas de
questions
c'est le concept du rechargement complet
mais bien sûr je vais donc vous
expliquer un tour pour que vous puissiez
à votre tour bluffé les gens dès cet
après midi dès ce soir dès demain dès
cette semaine mais vous m'avez souvent
demandées dans les commentaires si je
pouvais faire le tour à quelqu'un pour
prouver que c'était bluffant et que ça
fonctionnait eh bien il ya quelques
secondes j'ai fait ce tour-là à leonard
sur ma chaîne sur sa chaîne donc avant
de vous l'expliquer j'aimerais que vous
viviez le moment en fait quitté ma vidéo
vraiment cliqué sur léonard clic et
sinon sur la petite fiche au dessus de
léonard est allé voir la vidéo
allez voir le tour tel que juif est
comme ça vous aurez peut-être des débuts
d'idées et vous revenez ici vous
reprenez la vidéo là je vais faire un
clap comme ça sera plus facile à
retrouver pour vous du coup tu vas
découvrir les explications on a
exactement
et si un peu pas de les découvrir sur
l'a8 je te dis franchement vers la bibl
en fait tu as juste d'être bluffé et
juste derrière elle explique qu'en
magicien de faire un tour tu as toujours
envie de se connecter des applications
des explications première j'avais donc
une prédiction que j'avais à graffer qui
était si j'aurais pu ne pas l'aggraver
on s'en fiche et j'avais un jeu de
cartes le jeu de cartes en fait c'est un
forçage mais je lis un peu déguisé à la
fin il fallait absolument que tu es le
cadre de piquet lh2 coeur ces deux
cartes là les ennemis tous les deux sur
le dessus du jeu je t'ai demandé de
choisir un nom de n'importe lequel tu as
10 4 ouais j'ai dit 4 on aurait pu dire
n'importe quoi je voulais mais en l'air
comme ça vous allez suivre le trajet
qu'elles font si tu m'avais dit aux tu
vois qu'un nombre impair le souci ça
aurait fait une deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit neuf dix ans
ok la personne donc elle donne les
cartes autant que le nombre quel à la
pensée et après je t'ai dis tu divises
tu fais gauche droite gauche droite
gauche droite
donc quoi qu'il arrive les deux
dernières cartes que tu donneras c'était
les deux qui étaient sur le dessus du
paquet au tout départ en fait elles sont
descendues elles sont remontées et
l'explication pour laquelle je choisis
ah oui donc ça c'est une deuxième mardi
la raison alors je vais vous dire
quelque chose
le tour il esafe à 100% c'est plus de la
magie que du mentalisme l'a donc quoi
qu'il arrive je vais réussir mais ça
peut être un très bon entraînement pour
vous pour vous entraîner à forcer une
carte psychologiquement via les autres
vidéos que je vous ai déjà expliqué ci
si je veux m'entraîner à forcer une dame
de coeur avec des moore avec un discours
spécifique par exemple j'aurais pu
mettre la dame de coeur ici j'essaie de
te la force et psychologiquement
et si je rate de toute manière j'ai la
suite du tour qui va faire que quoi
qu'il arrive ça va fonctionner je vois
une espèce de fuite et de se voir le
filet de secours c'est ce petit papier
de bristol que j'ai fait ce matin et sur
lequel vous vous souvenez talent et
choisi le cadre de pique je crois oui ça
j'ai sur lequel vient voir il y avait
marqué effectivement 4 de pique en fait
il marqué 4 2 peak ici mais y avons
marqué également d'autres choeurs ici à
deux coeurs obligatoirement et quatre
issues de l'autre donc en fait suivant
comment je déplie donc le seul jeu vous
fait voir j'ai juste plier la feuille en
quatre départs j'ai fait le point
d'interrogation j'ai marqué de notre
coeur là et après je me suis dit comment
je peux le déplier sans qu'il le voit
donc j'ai déplié comme ça comme ça et je
marque et 4 2 peak ici comme n'ya que
deux solutions c'est facile d'en cacher
donc tous les cas en fête aurait eu là
une réponse donc pour te bluffé toi ou
pour vous quand vous allez bluffé les
gens qui vous allez faire quoi qu'il
arrive est la bonne solution
et comme je vous disais si par contre
vous voulez vous en profitez pour vous
entraîner à faire un vrai forçage
psychologique ça vous permet d'avoir un
filet de secours si vous vous raté ça
c'est plutôt cool mais ça c'est cool
tueur mais du coup si tu aurais voulu
faire un forçage psychologique tu
utilises très près comment alors j'aurai
pas forcément choisi ces cartes là qui
sont assez proches l'une de l'autre ces
deux cartes faible où il n'y a pas
beaucoup de couleurs il ya juste le
rouge et le noir par exemple pris 1,3
spontanément au compte de 3 tu vas en
choisir une donc c'est quand tu veux tu
prends celle que tu veut peut-être les
rouges qui sont plus dans le coeur ou
peut-être les noirs qui correspondent à
des personnalités plus ferme et plus
assumer vas-y et tu vois je serai voilà
c'est comme ça trois plein de fois
j'aurais placé une valeur sûre le noir
et j'ai essayé de façon même si je
n'aurais pas choisi une 3 bat à vue hier
exactement les filets de secours ça peut
être une bonne idée pour s'entraîner ça
va tu as tout compris mais là j'ai tout
compris et j'espère que vous aussi
paraît du coup si léonard a compris
c'est votre délégué de classe
aujourd'hui exactement
j'espère que cette vidéo ensemble vous a
plu j'espère que vous êtes allé voir la
vidéo de léonard et surtout vous en avez
profité pour vous abonner
regardez une
mes vidéos préférées toi c'est 2010
versus 2016 si vous l'avez pas vu
regarder la merci beaucoup de regarder
cette explication du dimanche bluffé le
genre à votre tour
n'hésitez pas à nous laisser un petit
commentaire je le regarde tous et je
suis sûr qu'il va y jeter un oeil
léonard et surtout un petit pouce en
l'air
poussan large et peu le temps de le
faire il ya mentaliser mon pouce oui
laissez-nous un pouce en l'air et avant
de partir n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
à la chaîne puisque le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
ah non mais tu as well as l'air prend
des vacances
bonne chance donc rendez vous demain à
17h ciao